[Applaudissements]
en fait j'ai reçu un appel puisque j'ai
travaillé en 2015 pour
TIMS Africa et puis bon ben comme on
peut l'imaginer les présidents de
fédération en Afrique entretiennent de
bonnes relations et étant qualifié au
championnat du monde
les Nigériens parce qu'elles étaient
championnes d'Afrique donc il a fallu
bien évidemment faire le déplacement et
elles ont pas de coach donc c'est le
président de la Fédération sud-africaine
qui m'a recommandé au président de la
Fédération nigérienne voilà et me voici
[Musique]
les difficiles de parler de niveau ici
on est on est dans une compétition de
très haut niveau à deux ans des JO les
championnats du monde ils sont tous en
pleine préparation nous au Nigéria il y
a d'autres problématiques c'est-à-dire
il y a pas vraiment d'entraîneur il y a
un seul vélo de Drôme il y a des
problématiques d'argent et puis aussi
comment expliquer
des différences de mentalités
un nigeri une nigérienne
n'a pas la culture de la performance il
y a d'autres problématiques sociales en
Afrique avant de penser à performer dans
le sport voilà donc c'est un petit peu
difficile
[Musique]
la relation avec les filles est
excellente le président est sympa et
puis ensuite on se bat avec nos moyens
on a des vélos
qui sont en dessous de 2000 euros par
rapport au vélo de 25000 ou 30 000 euros
de certains donc on a une technologie il
y a 20 ou 30 ans mais bon c'est pas on
est devenu un petit peu le chouchou du
public le public a compris donc c'est
bien la preuve que les gens ont compris
l'équipe d'Allemagne nous a offert du
matériel parce qu'ils ont vu pendant les
compétitions qu'on manquait de matériel
donc c'est quand même très très sympa
l'équipe d'Allemagne nous a offert cinq
guidons de poursuites donc voilà c'est
vraiment des gens me saluent dans le
milieu me félicite bravo donc c'est
vraiment très très sympa
[Applaudissements]